how's it going resumes period welcome
back to see Meg I always do that voice
welcome back to some more core funny I
haven't even started the game yet let's
start chapter 5 holy [ __ ]
wow it's the last chapter mind God so I
hear this one has all the different
endings that you can play of course
we're gonna watch the intro I love he
needs an intro of course in a teenager
is it I just wanted to lose
consciousness
the deepest part of my brain had become
thoroughly clouded over
and there were moments when I felt as
though I had almost slipped away slipped
away but the intense pain would always
wrench me back to my senses before I
would could follow through I would have
welcomed leaving a my mom mentor a loss
of consciousness with open arms but any
sort of respite from my suffering was
plainly denied me the only possible
escape was dead and yes it was certainly
at hand but it was taking an eternity to
reach me it was I was like a cell
shellfish removed from its shell I know
my fate but only the chef could make the
end camp and she was savoring my torment
what a mean chef oh god yeah I remember
what a tendon ow oh God
she's not gonna die a say ah okay studio
hustle me the gun Kuhn and immerse us a
little ring in the left eye serum mo
kurushimi notice Laney
superlight you're a tenacious one aren't
you awaken anything what the [ __ ] yeah
thanks that's comforting
Jesus style ready then simply I said
what the [ __ ] this is two [ __ ] out name
nor Zico Honua
son need I gotta stole Asami's his own
studio
yeah yeah we knew that
nice [ __ ] yeah that's how you wake up
like a man oh god I think this is done
some money fruit I wanna lick his nips I
know he's evil but I want you oh oh oh
no I don't want to get the wrong ending
now okay apparently the choice doesn't
matter
this is stay silent then grin I think
you kiss it's my favorite to follow
because I'm I'm more curious about her
and then the rest what's gonna happen I
guess everything else have happened with
the psycho and no me and Satoshi and all
that
I also the blonde guy and his his girl I
like
Sultana
kauahikaua Corrado cheese mega oak decay
is that big eyes haha
mega Jackson
oh cool yoku Cana a blue schmuck what
does that mean
oh oh oh he went there
oh no he went there Oh
swallows that's not good that's when you
know you're [ __ ]
Ron yoga oh god don't don't die please I
had known you didn't do your bat then
nothing at all you know when you talk
Widow I am your big breath
what could no more talk chavita what was
it a Saigon a song called a proper
response I would say sayonara [ __ ] so
chewy Stan Okoye vaisakhi War II
couldn't
oh you got why do we doubt what happened
downstairs huh I can save thank God save
station save station what happened dad
stays OMFG what happened were we able to
walk down stairs before I don't think so
I'm not to shout out oh oh he fell down
yet
does she look let me look alright
oh not under oh don't you dare touch it
Jesus you pee yourself
no [ __ ] way man kicked they're so
hard oh my god so he's the kid oh my god
I didn't realize my arena ciudad Mariko
oh my our enemy gotta stop at all it's
you know them are in Ohio
oh boy
oh my shoes shoe but what
rania counter-steer not turn on by
[ __ ] what is he doing oh damn
we're gonna change character come on I
want to know what's gonna happen
oh oh no what's happening to her
I don't want to know anymore okay Tammy
oh great Oh Sookie koko de uranium
ubukata cinema the other noise over
sonic Oh mm hi
so no make our mama tell Gary oh snap oh
time to run yuka time to run time to run
time to run all right now all right now
all right it's time to run shhh
here we go please help me ah [ __ ] again
god damn it
never say never dead man ever say never
never never say never
I'm sure probably not going there hey
don't worry me let's go back up there
must be so many shut up I'm not to fret
okay oh wait no no no no now now now now
neo neo [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Doug Doug
dad deck deck deck all right it's not
here yes we go go go yeah I believe in
you I believe in you catch em where do
we go serious just have to keep running
keep running you can be strong oh yeah
he can't go up here Kenny okay what is
this Ayana me--some he shouldn't be able
to walk up here alright because he
doesn't have the shoes only I have the
shoes
hey as Jose I repeat he has shows god
dammit alright alright you see me I kind
of got that huh what the key to the
franchise my god alright now we just
have to make it back somehow
[ __ ] don't be at the end of the hallway
don't be I did it thank you
I'm so [ __ ] cow ASA [ __ ] you now wait
we're not done [ __ ] how God is there
oh my god is it here where is it I
forgot to come out a little sorry we
have to go down here
or was it up Oh God I don't it was up
fact ah alright we're good
don't cry you got to keep your no no
this is very bad
this is very very very very bad I'm
sorry all right all right all right all
right all right all right
trick timber the stays the stair trick
it's done that since fourth grade I
think there we go now again I will not
eco Dara with you I'll be fine yes
go go go go go video cast an okay don't
cry don't cry for me you catchin this
way hurry she said that in one word all
right well then can I try stay there
where is she oh oh she must be so tired
oh god Justin oh [ __ ] and your face my
god they're cooperating what the what is
happening here whose good is evil I
don't understand we actually gonna play
it in
why is he what
why does he care
this is this one night Jesus my toaster
Cory I see all my sin oh yeah my is one
with the penis hair Oh back sorry yay
the philosophy on it okay but y-you know
you ready MA
meanin REI de tokyo sir Intimidator casa
no Maya it's horrible
Oh myoh massacre non-union doctor which
says that da who says that because you
know know yet storm or come a [ __ ] and I
go yes I'm sure that's what you saw well
do crocoduck you might as a kite a nine
died
it's not here Ananda each document icon
Patek right there
I saw what I saw you know MA yo I mean
that is karate now your Denis Ganga
lucky duck hit it off well maybe that's
because you take pictures of dead bodies
mr. wild guess where do you get across
the night mom
I mean math garden you got this conical
oh is he a pianist what luck up there
you seem nice but who is he I don't
understand what are you got seated here
tonight oh I've been a curse curse
cutter I saw multi-target on Sikandar
oh my oh my you know so no Konya what's
the real reason she gained a greater
sorrow coiny oh they asked you out at
8-under
what the only kinda my stove in the
suffering of other is the only way of
keeping the same and I am so so that's
why attack sir that's not
stylist se Sita Simbu hormonal Ananya
scooty mono nice communai hey ray BIA
gonna talk that's no spider
you suck suck on a rocket on your insane
already I'm sorry about that
now come on
hmm okay sighs ty kuroneko cuttlefish
Totsuka you got to go at a time in game
ducked under seen that on a sec I gotta
Monica there is some crazy [ __ ] right
there
um that's awkward
my you know
what [ __ ] oh my god that is some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] you have to be in the such
Kunichika I don't know
Cuttino canonical groceries me each day
dr. komoti can cross a constant Inara
sato state autonomy not there you have a
holiday that's twice you need go
Domino's citizen mama you really know
Terra Nova
Yuuka another one how they look like
them together okay
- amen what Jesus that's gonna happen I
think I get separated
oh no oh no oh Jesus
oh my god oh my freaking level all right
you're gonna have to end the first
episode of chapter 5 here hope you
enjoyed watching go ahead and leave a
like if you did brass I really
appreciate it and it makes me give you
this say on somebody tomorrow love you
MA